hey this is pressure Locker every day
you walk from point A to point B which
is two miles away
50% of the days you can walk the path
with no obstruction the other 50% of the
day's a troll appears at the halfway
point and blocks your trip the troll
also enables an invisible barrier
blocking your trip one mile in either
direction
forcing you to walk around it to
complete your journey you cannot see or
detect the barrier until you're halfway
between a and B so you cannot plan in
advance whether you need to walk around
it but you do know the troll appears
randomly 50% of the time if you can walk
in straight line segments between any
points between a and B what is your best
strategy to walk the least distance on
average what is that distance give this
prom a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for the solution
we'll get started by considering the
worst case scenario
imagine the troll is always there and
you need to walk on the barrier every
single time you'd walk from point A to
the end of the barrier and then complete
your trip you'd be walking the
hypotenuse of a right triangle with the
leg of one this gives a distance of the
square root of two you need to walk two
of these distances the total amount
you'd be walking is two times the square
root of two which is approximately two
point eight three miles but you can do
better than this imagine instead you
simply try and walk straight and then
walk around the barrier only if needed
50% of the days there's no troll and
there's no obstruction you can simply
walk a two mile path between a and B the
other 50% of the days you will get
blocked by the invisible barrier and the
troll so you'll walk one mile you'll get
blocked by the barrier so you'll have to
walk one mile around it and then you can
complete your trip which is the square
root of two you'd expect to walk the sum
of these distances which is two plus the
square root of two
the average you'd expect to walk is the
average of these two cases this ends up
being 2 plus 1/2 square root of 2 which
is approximately 2.7 1
can you do better than this the answer
is yes the solution is you need to
consider walking something in between
these two extreme cases imagine you walk
a distance X above the halfway point now
if there is no troll you can simply
complete your trip to point B if there
is a troll you need to walk around the
barrier but you've already walked some
distance X up so that'll save you the
amount you'll need to walk around the
barrier so let's calculate the distances
in both cases 50% of the day there is no
troll so you can simply walk to point B
the distance you walk is the hypotenuse
this is the square root of 1 plus x
squared and need to walk two of these in
the other 50% of the cases there is a
troll and you're going to need to walk
around this barrier so you walk this
distance up X then you walk around and
then you complete your trip so the first
distance is the same hypotenuse now
instead of having to walk a full
distance one up you can walk 1 minus X
up and then you complete your square
root of 2 journey to the end so the
total distance you walk is the sum of
these distances the expected distance
will be the average of these two cases
so we'll average these two distances and
we'll get an expected distance that you
walk in terms of the function X we want
to minimize this distance so you could
take the derivative with respect to X
and solve for the minimum value after
setting the derivative equal to 0 this
ends up being X is equal to
approximately 0.35 we substitute that
back into our distance function and we
get that you expect to walk about 2.6 2
miles so that's one way to solve this
problem I'm going to present another way
so from the start you can't really know
which distance you're going to walk up
but you could have a compass and you
could say well I'm going to walk some
angle up so imagine we walk some angle
theta from the starting point we'll
proceed the same way we did when we're
walking some distance X so 50% of the
time there's no troll so we can complete
our trip we need to calculate the
potenuse in terms of the angle theta
this will be one divided by cosine of
theta and we walk two of these and the
other case we're going to walk around
the invisible barrier so we walk the
hypotenuse we walk around it and then we
complete our trip this hypotenuse is one
over the cosine of theta the other leg
of the triangle would be the tangent of
theta so the distance we walk up would
be one minus the tangent of theta and
then we complete the square root of two
so we add up these distances to get the
amount that we'd walk we now calculate
the expected distance as the average of
these two cases so now we get the
expected distance you walk as a function
of theta that we want to minimize you
can take the derivative this with
respect to theta set it equal to zero
and get the theta is equal to the
inverse sine of one-third which is
approximately nineteen and a half
degrees so how can we solve for the
distance we walk well this is a good
teaching point if we know that theta is
equal to the inverse sine of one-third
that means we have a right triangle
where what the opposite leg is one and
the hypotenuse is three we could solve
for the remaining leg using the
Pythagorean theorem we can then solve
for the cosine and the tangent of the
angle theta we can substitute these
values back into our distance function
and we end up with the same result that
you expect to walk approximately two
point six two miles did you figure this
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math tune game theory you can
catch run on my blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Walker and if you like
this video please check out my books
their links in the video description